I read your paper it contains some
exceptional science my instinct is that
there is another element you think you
found an undiscovered element science is
changing and the very people who are
running science believed the world was
flat leave my laboratory if my science
doesn't speak for itself then you have
gravely misunderstood it I'm going to
prove them wrong we all saw that atoms
were finite and stable well some of them
are not I have called this radioactivity
no discovery could cure cancer
you change the world our works been
nominated for the Nobel Prize the
commendation only mentions my name
they stole my brilliant how dare you
take their applause this is bigger than
both I just want to do good science
there are those that say that Radian is
making them sick the question can be
raised where the mankind benefits from
knowing the secrets of nature
I have been haunted my entire life
trying to understand the impossible
this is my fight and I will win it
[Applause]
[Music]